with us I don't think we most military
don't look at it that way we don't
calculate that I might not come home
that's that's like a factor that's never
calculated into our decision-making
process our biggest thing is we might
let the guy down next to us so for us
it's our training to kind of go over
there and execute our mission that's our
biggest thing in the Marine Corps pushes
that mission accomplishment mission
accomplishment you know then troop
welfare and I think with that mindset we
go in we're already pretty prepared for
what's going to go on you know for me
engaging the enemy or anything I always
kind of thought I was doing what I was
trained to do and I kind of separated a
motion from it and and I've gotten
better at it over the years every
deployment I went back I understood that
emotion is only weakness over here for
me I got my must think objectively I
don't
general mattis always says a phrase no
better friend no worst enemy and I think
it's like the best sink is really--it's
it kind of explains what the fighting
man has to kind of do over there but
it's very hard it's hard to go over
there without emotion it's you know
after one of your friends gets hit by a
roadside bomb it's hard not to be pissed
but the truth is you got to realize hey
this is the nature of the beast
I got a drive on I'm not gonna take it
out on other Iraqis that aren't involved
you know
um I got hit by a rocket-propelled
grenade and April 7 2004 9 Ischl push
into Fallujah um for me we got we got
slammed rut going into an ambush and we
were the point vehicle it actually blew
off my assistant team leader both his
hands Eddie right it broke my arm blew
off my trigger finger and it wounded
everyone else in my vehicle what we did
we pushed out of the Killzone and
actually got stuck in a secondary kill
zone where we were surrounded by about
26 guys and we had to do medical aid to
ourselves but I put a tourniquet on and
one of my young lance corporals Lance
Corporal Maison actually turning kitted
up Eddie but for us it was actually kind
of funny because this is it's like that
Marine Corps humor that you see that see
throughout the series
Eddie writes in the backseat cracking
jokes and the guy has no hands and for
me it's like calm breeds calm so I'm
like shit if this guy is laughing about
this you know how can I be worried I'm
definitely not as bad as he is and he
actually made a bad situation kind of
somewhat entertaining and then we just
went back and we just executed what we
trained for because in heights high
levels of stress you always resort back
to your last highest level of training
for me this is my third combat tour so
it wasn't like I was worried I just I
just kind of is everything was muscle
memory I did what we had to do to
survive it we got back out of the kill
zone and probably hour and a half two
hours later we were met it backed out of
there
I always kind of promised that I was
gonna I was gonna make things right for
Eddie I was kind of you know after
seeing him in the hospital actually
brought me to tears seen him in ICU
it's hard I don't know it's hard to said
I want to say I want to go kill a bunch
of people to get back you know revenge
because I you know then again that's
kind of you know using me up my emotion
part but I wanted I wanted to make it
feel like that we were wounded that day
for something you know it wasn't for
nothing I wanted to get back there and
and try and fix the problems Iraq had
and if that meant fight it meant fight
if that meant fix the infrastructure or
work with the local Iraqis do whatever I
can
whatever is in my power to make that
place better and I learned a lot because
my fourth bit tours were totally
different than what you see in
Generation Kill a lot of what I did is
actually live with Iraqis now to 24-man
platoon and we created kind of an
atmosphere where they could be safer
where they're around we learned off then
we learned everything from how to cook
their their flatbread their hobus to how
to hook up Italian porn on their TVs to
teaching them how to patrol you know and
working with these people closely and
try and get rid of everything from the
criminal and that's that's like running
loose in Iraq to work with the
terrorists and the other elements that
are there because it's very complex and
I learned so much more of my my fourth
and fifth tour then I could ever imagine
I mean I kind of look back at my first
multiple tours and it's like wow if I
knew what I knew now you know we could
have done such a better job back then
we did it on this place called porkchop
island is like I think in the history of
the world I don't think anyone's been
injured on that island but for me is
like getting back on the horse and I was
actually paranoid I actually kind of had
well it must be what Captain America
fell into I have one a very paranoid
because I was calculating and everything
every combat I've seen in the past like
possible ambushes that can go down and
everything in my mind was just racing
and and I was like man why why did I
come back here and I think after I got
over there it's just like one day of
extreme paranoia for some reason but
after that I went back to just pushing a
motion to the side and doing my job and
I had no problem